♪ ♪
>> Laura: LES SEPTEMBER
GOVERNOR RON DeSANTIS STEPPED
IN TO HELP FLORIDA RESIDENTS WHO
WERE FACING ABSURD COVERT
PENALTIES.
>>
ALL OUTSTANDING FINES AND
PENALTIES THAT HAVE BEEN APPLIED
AGAINST INDIVIDUALS ARE
SUSPENDED.
I THINK WE NEED TO GET AWAY FROM
TRYING TO PENALIZE PEOPLE FOR
SOCIAL DISTANCING AND WORK WITH
PEOPLE CONSTRUCTIVELY.
>> Laura: DESPITE THAT, SOME
VINDICTIVE FLORIDA COUNTIES ARE
STILL PUNISHING THEIR OWN
RESIDENTS LIKE IN BROWARD COUNTY
WHERE FORMER GYM OWNERS JILLIAN
AND MIKE FACE POSSIBLE JAIL
TIME, UNBELIEVABLE, FOR NOT
COMPLYING WITH LOCAL MASK
MANDATES.
THEY JOINED ME NOW ALONG WITH
THEIR ATTORNEY COREY STROLLER.
ALSO WITH US, FOR THE
GOVERNOR RON DeSANTIS, WHO'S
BEEN FOLLOWING THE STORY VERY
CLOSELY.
MIKE, I WANT TO START WITH YOU.
YOU'VE BEEN ARRESTED THREE TIMES
OVER THE MASKS MACK >> IT'S HARD
TO BELIEVE, ISN'T IT, LAURA?
>> Laura: NO, I JUST CAN'T
EVEN BELIEVE THIS IS THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA WHEN
I'M HEARING THIS.
WHAT HAPPENED?
>> SO TWO MONTHS AFTER JAMES
REOPENED IN SOUTH FLORIDA,
BROWARD COUNTY CAME DOWN WITH A
MANDATE SAYING THE OFFICIAL
COVERINGS HAD TO BE WORN DURING
STRENUOUS EXERCISE.
24 -- YOU KNOW, WE FILED A
LAWSUIT AGAINST BROWARD COUNTY.
24 HOURS AFTER THE LAWSUIT FILED
WE WERE ARRESTED.
WE WERE ARRESTED THREE TIMES IN
TOTAL.
THEY SEIZED OUR BUSINESS.
THEY OFFERED US TEN DAYS IN
JAIL, WE DECLINE FAT AND NOW I'M
LOOKING AT SIX MONTHS IN PRISON.
THEY ALSO ARRESTED JILLIAN HERE
AS WELL.
>> Laura: DOES THIS SEEM LIKE
THE COUNTRY YOU GREW UP IN?
>> DEFINITELY DEFINITELY NOT.
IT BARELY FEELS LIKE AMERICA.
>> Laura: CORY, WHAT ARE THE
PROSPECTS HERE OF GETTING ANY
ASSISTANCE OR HELP?
>> WELL, WE REALLY AT THIS POINT
HAVE TO RELY ON
GOVERNOR DeSANTIS AND I HATE
TO PUT IT IN HIS LAP AND HIS
JACKET OF GENERAL COUNSEL'S LAP,
BUT WE GOT A POLITICAL ACTIVIST
JUDGE THAT ORIGINALLY TOLD MIKE
AND JILLIAN BEFORE I WAS EVER
RETAINED THAT THE STATE WAS
OFFERING A DIVERSION PROGRAM AND
THE JUDGE SAID -- IT WAS THE
JUDGE THAT SAID THE ONLY
RESOLUTION HE WOULD APPROVE IS A
TEN DAY JAIL SENTENCE FOR MIKE
IN JAIL, AND THAT IS BEFORE
JILLIAN'S CASE WAS TRANSFERRED
IN, SO THE WAY BROWARD STATE
CHARGED IT, MIKE IS FACING
ACTUALLY TWO SECOND-DEGREE
MISDEMEANOR FOR A TOTAL OF 120
DAYS IN JAIL AND JILLIAN IS
FACING ONE FOR A TOTAL OF 60
DAYS IN JAIL, ALL FOR BASICALLY
NOT HAVING PEOPLE WHERE MASKS
WHILE EXERCISING.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
>> Laura: THIS IS INSANITY.
GOVERNOR DeSANTIS, IT SOUNDS
LIKE BROWARD IS THUMBING THEIR
NOSE AT YOU.
YOU'VE BEEN VERY PRO-REOPENING,
GETTING RID OF THESE MANDATES.
WHAT THE HECK IS GOING ON HERE
AND WHAT CAN YOU DO?
>> WELL, IT'S A TOTAL OVERREACH,
LAURA.
THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT WE ORDERED
AGAINST LAST SUMMER MANY, MANY
MONTHS AGO AND SO I WAS ACTUALLY
JUST RECENTLY BRIEFED ON THIS
CASE AND WE LOOKED AT IT AND SO
I'M GLAD YOU HAVE MIKE AND
JILLIAN ON ANIMAL SO GLAD TO BE
ON TO BE ABLE TO SAY THAT
EFFECTIVE TOMORROW MORNING, I'M
GOING TO SIGN A REPRIEVE UNDER
MY CONSTITUTIONAL AUTHORITY, SO
THAT WILL DELAY THE CASE FOR 60
DAYS AGAINST BOTH OF THEM AND
THEN WHEN OUR CLEMENCY BOARD
MEETS IN THE COMING WEEKS, WE
WILL ISSUE PARDONS NOT ONLY FOR
MIKE AND JILLIAN, BUT FOR ANY
FLORIDIAN WHO MAY HAVE
OUTSTANDING INFRACTIONS FOR
THINGS LIKE MASKS AND SOCIAL
DISTANCING.
THE FACT IS --
>> Laura: WOW.
>> NOT EVEN RIGHT TO BE WEARING
MASKS WHEN YOU'RE EXERCISING.
THE WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION'S
ADVISE IT AGAINST IT.
IT'S UNHEALTHY FOR PEOPLE TO BE
DOING THAT IN THE FIRST PLACE,
SO IT WAS A BAD RESTRICTION, BUT
THESE THINGS WITH HEALTH SHOULD
BE ADVISORY, THEY SHOULD NOT BE
PUNITIVE AND SO WE ARE HAPPY TO
USE OUR CONSTITUTIONAL
AUTHORITY.
I THINK THEY'VE BEEN TREATED
POORLY AND FORTUNATELY THEY GOT
A GOVERNOR THAT CARES.
>> Laura: WOW.
HOW DOES THAT FEEL?
YOU JUST GOT YOUR REPRIEVE ON
NATIONAL TELEVISION.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH,
GOVERNOR DeSANTIS.
WE APPRECIATE THAT A LOT.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Laura: --
>> Laura: YOU BUILT YOUR
BUSINESS WITH LITERALLY YOUR
SWEAT AND GOVERNOR, I KNOW
YOU'VE SEEN THIS ALL ACROSS THE
STATES.
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS, AMERICAN,
NATIVE-BORN INDIVIDUALS COMING
HERE AS IMMIGRANTS, THEY WORK
THEIR TAIL OFF FOR THESE
BUSINESSES AND THEN THERE --
THEY LOSE EVERYTHING BECAUSE OF
A MASK MANDATE?
>> YEAH, WELL, IT'S NOT RIGHT
AND BEASLEY WE ARE GOING TO BE
ABLE --
>> Laura: WE LOST THE
GOVERNOR, BUT THAT THE, I'VE GOT
TO SAY, WAS WILD.
THEY DID NOT KNOW THAT THAT
REPRIEVE WAS COMING.
THE CLEMENCY BOARD WILL MEET
AND, JILLIAN, POLICE SAY THAT
YOUR ARREST, BY THE WAY ON
AUGUST 7TH, THEY SAY WAS
WARRANTED BECAUSE YOU BROUGHT
WORKOUT EQUIPMENT OUTSIDE?
WAIT A SECOND, KNOWING WHAT WE
KNOW ABOUT OUTDOOR SPREAD NOW,
THIS IS ABSURD THEY ARRESTED YOU
FOR SOMETHING THAT IS NOT
DANGEROUS AND THAT IS HEALTHY TO
BE OUTSIDE EXERCISING.
IT YOU ARE ARRESTED FOR THAT.
I DIDN'T EVEN KNOW THAT UNTIL I
JUST SAW THAT.
>> THAT'S CORRECT.
I WAS ARRESTED OUTSIDE OF MY
CLOSED BUSINESS DURING A
PEACEFUL PROTEST.
>> Laura: CORY, YOU
REPRESENTED A LOT OF PEOPLE,
WE'RE LOOKING AT THE VIDEO NOW.
NICE BARBELLS.
LOOKING AT THE VIDEO NOW, THIS
IS -- ALL THESE JUDGES WHO HAVE
DONE THIS, ALL THESE POLITICIANS
WHO HAVE TOLERATED THIS AND WHO
HAVE ADVOCATED THIS, THEY'VE ALL
GOT TO THROWN OUT OF OFFICE.
I MEAN, THIS IS SUCH AN
OVERREACH, IT'S SICKENING.
>> I CAN'T AGREE MORE AND THEN
TO SAY THAT MY CLIENT BELONGED
IN JAIL FOR SOMETHING THAT WAS
ACTUALLY TAKEN BACK WHEN BROWARD
FINALLY DID REALIZE YOU DON'T
HAVE TO WEAR MASKS WHILE
EXERCISING AND YOU HAVE A JUDGE
THAT WANTS TO PUT THEM IN JAIL
WHEN THE STATE WAS POSSIBLY
GOING TO THROW OUT THE CASE IS
RIDICULOUS.
POLITICAL ACTIVISTS, JUDGES NEED
TO BE REMOVED.
>> Laura: WE HAVE THE GOVERNOR
BACK.
GOVERNOR, YOUR BACK.
FINAL WORDS ON WHAT YOU WILL NO
LONGER TOLERATE.
WE GOT 20 SECONDS.
>> NO FINES, NO PENALTIES, WE'VE
GOT TO MOVE FORWARD AS A STATE.
WE ARE THE OASIS OF FREEDOM,
THAT'S WHY FLORIDA IS DOING
WELL, SO LET'S BUILD OFF THAT
AND LET'S NOT GO BACKWARDS ON
ANY OF THI